[موسيقى]
في
قاعدة عسكرية تم اجتياحها مؤخرًا في شمال
أفغانستان ،
تعرض طالبان للأسلحة
الثقيلة والذخيرة التي تم الاستيلاء عليها
CNN للتحقق من
صحة مقاطع الفيديو أو تاريخ تصويرها
، ولم يتمكن مسؤولو الأمن الأفغان من
تأكيد أو نفي
مزاعم طالبان في مقاطع الفيديو هذه لـ CNN
لكنهم يعترفون بخسارة عشرات
البلدات
في الأسبوعين الماضيين ، حيث حقق طالبان
90 انتصارًا من هذا القبيل في الشهر الماضي
، وتقول الأمم المتحدة إنها أقل من 50 أو 370
انتصارًا ، لكنها لا تزال مقلقة للغاية بالنسبة
لمعظم المناطق التي تم الاستيلاء عليها
حول
عواصم المحافظات مما يشير إلى أن
طالبان هي  تمركز نفسها
لمحاولة الاستيلاء على هذه العواصم بمجرد
انسحاب القوات الأجنبية بالكامل في بعض الأحيان ، يدعي طالبان
الانتصار دون إطلاق رصاصة
في محافظة الطاهر ، قام جنود حكوميون بتسليم رتل كامل من
عربات همفي عسكرية أفغانية الصنع مدرعة من
قبل
جنود الحكومة لطالبان.
بنادقهم في كومة
دفعة ثمينة
لطالبان الذين يقاتلون
مئات الأميال  يقول
المسؤولون الحكوميون الأفغان
إنهم يرسلون تعزيزات لاستعادة
السيطرة ويزعمون دون دليل أنهم قتلوا
مئات من
طالبان ، ويبدو أن هجوم طالبان يستغل
انسحاب الولايات المتحدة وحلف الناتو مما يحد من
الدعم الجوي للقوات الأفغانية.  على
الأرض ويثير تساؤلات حول نيتهم
حادثات السلام في الدوحة مع الحكومة الأفغانية ، م
المهم أيضًا أنهم يه
جمون الشمال ، لقد غطيت ال
راع الأفغاني في التسعينيات عندما كان طا
بان يقاتلون في طريقهم إلى ال
لاد ، الأمر استغرق سن
ات منهم  للصعود إلى الشمال ، فإن هذا
سيرسل رسالة تقشعر
لها الأبدان إلى الأفغان ،
كما أن زيادة طالبان مصدر قلق أيضًا للقوات الأمريكية
التي وافقت على وقف إطلاق النار مع
طالبان
مع خروجهم من أطول حرب لهم ، لكنهم
كانوا يأملون أن يغادروا
البلاد بسلام كل يوم.  يتغير الوضع في
أفغانستان مع
استمرار طالبان
في شن هذه الهجمات
ومداهمة مراكز المقاطعات أيضًا
حيث أن العنف الذي لا يزال مرتفعا
يوم الجمعة يلتقي الرئيس الأفغاني أشرف غني
بالرئيس
بايدن مع القوات الأمريكية الأخيرة التي بذل فيها أكثر من
نصفهم
صعوبة لرؤية عكس سهل
لمكاسب طالبان
نيك روبرتسون سي إن لندن